San Diego Comic-Con 2019 has brought big news
for fans of the greenest girl in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Thanks to a panel discussion with Avengers:
Endgame writers Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely, as well as directors Joe and Anthony
Russo, we finally have an answer to a huge
question about the post-Endgame fate of Gamora,
a fan-favorite member of the Guardians of
the Galaxy.
Of course, some questions will always remain
unanswered.
"Why is Gamora?!"
According to Vanity Fair, Markus and McFeely
revealed that Zoe Saldana's alien assassin
is indeed alive and well in the aftermath
of Tony Stark's momentous snap at the end
of Endgame the one that completely took out
Thanos' army of evildoers and creepy creatures.
Some fans were concerned that they may have
permanently lost Gamora to Tony's snap, considering
that, thanks to some time-travel antics, Avengers:
Endgame featured a past version of Gamora
who was still working with her adoptive father,
Thanos.
Marvel fans don't need to be reminded of present-day
Gamora's emotional death in Avengers: Infinity
War, where Thanos sacrificed her to snag the
Soul Stone and power his Infinity Gauntlet
during his quest for universal domination.
Watching her lose her life in Infinity War
was difficult and thinking that past Gamora
was a goner as well after the events of Endgame
was even more devastating to consider.
Ever since her first appearance in Guardians
of the Galaxy, Saldana's Gamora has charmed
audiences thanks to her intense fighting prowess,
her sharp wit and intelligence, and, of course,
her romantic entanglement with Peter Quill.
"There's another name you might know me by...
Star-Lord."
"Who?"
However, Star-Lord's fury over his fallen
love is one of the factors that led to Thanos'
"Snappening" at the close of Infinity War
in the first place.
When Quill emotionally attacked Thanos after
learning the news of Gamora's death, it gave
the supervillain the opportunity to overpower
the Avengers and ultimately snap away half
of all life across the entire universe.
Five years after Thanos' fateful Decimation,
the Avengers reunited in Endgame to attempt
a "time heist" in hopes of saving all of their
vanished friends and loved ones.
Despite several mishaps, it ended up working
out but one surprise guest returned along
with everyone else who was originally dusted.
When Thanos shot his army from 2014 into the
MCU's present, Gamora was suddenly back in
play, with a big catch.
This wasn't the version of Gamora that died
in Infinity War; rather, it was the 2014 Gamora
who was still firmly on her dad's side.
For this reason, fans debated whether or not
Gamora was spared during Tony Stark's sacrificial
snap during Endgame's big battle scene.
Even though it was possible that Tony's snap
didn't dust her and that she was still around
somewhere, Gamora didn't show up on Star-Lord's
radar when he went searching for her in the
final moments of Endgame.
The argument was still raging in May of 2019,
when the creative team behind Avengers: Endgame
simply stoked the flames by saying that Gamora's
fate could go either way.
During a chat with Business Insider, the Russos
said that Gamora may have been dusted, but
it was also possible that she survived the
snap.
They then stated that fans would just have
to wait until Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3 arrives in theaters to see for themselves.
To make matters more stressful, the Russos
also said Quill, who was looking for Gamora
at the end of Endgame, didn't know what had
happened to her either.
At that time, the Russo Brothers seemed happy
to put the burden of this particular reveal
on James Gunn, who is returning as the writer
and director of the third Guardians movie
but thankfully they've changed their tune
and revealed the truth ahead of schedule.
However, now that we know for sure that Gamora
is alive, there are still some obvious complications:
since she's the 2014 Gamora, she doesn't know
anything about the Avengers, and doesn't really
know who Peter Quill even is, which could
present some pretty awkward problems.
She and her sister Nebula could also still
potentially be at odds, despite the friendship
they forged throughout their previous adventures
together.
Saldana hasn't officially confirmed her return
in Guardians 3, but she did recently say that
she would love to play a more villainous version
of her signature Marvel character in the upcoming
sequel, so it stands to reason that Gamora
would be included in the final film of this
whimsical, irreverent film trilogy.
And since she was also one of the stars who
petitioned to reinstate Gunn after old tweets
initially got him fired from the third Guardians
film, the idea of Gunn not being behind the
camera is no longer standing in the way of
her returning.
For now, it remains to be seen just what type
of role Gamora will play in upcoming Marvel
films, but at the very least, it's comforting
to know that the MCU's favorite verdant warrior
is still out there somewhere, planning her
next move.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.